you noticed a nuclear yeah or like I
want a long-ass email box do you fight
TSA the way he does well I have don't
you get to you say pre I don't have that
oh you die the same airline I'm gonna do
that Ari Shaffir told me how to treat
TSA he fights every night fight them
every time and I just miss associated
when we're in the airport I go into
completely separate line because I don't
even want to pretend like I'll tell you
why here we go you're not a police
officer yet don't get me started okay
and I'm gonna say this all right
this question after after they see your
ticket and your ID you'll be like
putting your stuff on that little you
know mean belt thing right and they'll
go some some stranger will go where are
you going sir and I don't answer them
isn't there none of your [ __ ]
business I know you already saw my [ __ ]
yeah I'm not answering you all this [ __ ]
I had to go through to get to this point
yeah you know I hate him I I was in
Chicago and like for some reason aligned
with a little messed up so they had and
the latest lady was yelling at us you
know she was like you know yeah I was
like this is a customer service business
okay like what and then there was
luckily there was this white guy there
in a suit and he was like I need to see
this Jake manager so the manager comes
over and her name was cookie of course
oh like the show and she was just acting
up and I said to the guy I said let's
not act like this is the first time
you've got a complaint about her
attitude okay and they you know he was
just like trying not to be like I said
come on
like like learn some custom manners you
know like I feel like that's not a
government assigned job okay you
actually filled out an application and
was like I want to do this job it's like
dude it's like they have one application
for the post office
DMV parking enforcement and TSA and then
they just assign them because they all
have the same
I never ridiculous and doesn't think
it's not really their fault right it's
like they probably are told all these
things about rules and you know how do
or you know mean Isis you know I mean
and all these things a million people go
through the airport how many times you
think they'd stop a terrorist what how
many times do you think they stop a
terrorist at LAX because that [ __ ] will
be on the news we found a terrorist no
never has happened out of ten million
people there's probably one person yet
this is also dogs also that's not the
route they're gonna take the next time
because when they did 9/11 was such a
[ __ ] shock because no one had ever
really done that before
just steal our plans and use our planes
against us which I've said this before
was a [ __ ] genius
yeah idea but not wrong and evil but not
in the worst thing ever but not in the
long run and it did it's not like like
if you're Isis let me tell you that if
Isis this would be the stupidest thing
ever
if Isis did get a bomb and blew up some
city or anything like that all they
would do is poke the bear and then it
would be the only reason why we don't go
over there and just ransack the place as
it is it's because we police ourselves
you know we got the dog
we got people going no we don't want any
kids to die we don't want any families
to die we don't want any soldiers to die
if they killed hundreds of thousands of
people all that would mean it would just
be this should be over like this because
it'd be like Hiroshima Nagasaki yeah we
don't [ __ ] around
we don't [ __ ] around when it comes to no
we didn't we what we did after 9/11
wasn't enough I'm just saying what we
did after 9/11 the response hadn't made
no absolute sense we police ourselves so
what you're saying so what you're saying
right now is is that if there was even a
bigger like they killed a hundred
thousand people then what you're saying
that our response would be devastating
to them yes I don't think so no because
we would have the we would have the okay
cuz even that respond but just here's
the thing though we had the okay to go
into Afghanistan to find Osama bin Laden
right because that's what happened he
was in charge of 9/11 right instead we
went it into a country right and then we
took out Saddam Hussein who had nothing
to do with 9/11 so what I'm saying is is
that regardless of what they do to us
our
response is probably gonna be they're
not gonna make any [ __ ] sense look
about Homeland Security I'm more
conservative than I am liberal because I
liken it to like if we were playing
basketball on the yard and getting
serious yeah
there's always a guy just like man [ __ ]
y'all I'm gonna go to my trunk you know
and back in the hood that just means
this guy's got a gun in this room right
okay
now the difference between a liberal and
conservative the liberal is gonna let
him get to the trunk and kill three
people and then do something about it
the Conservatives gonna be like you're
not getting to the trunk we're gonna
beat your ass right here now check this
out
there may not be a gun in the trunk
right but the action was taken
yeah that's the difference between the
two No so the conservative the
conservative would go to somebody that
had nothing to do with the situation so
normal same was the gun the reason why
Laney had one reason why we have Isis in
the first place is because we'd
established a belies that region there
was a civil war we needed you stabilized
really to create Isis that's just a
byproduct of yeah and the worst
byproduct that we could imagine
look Bobby yeah we we've been over to
that place yeah we've been over to these
places we have they don't know how to
treat their own people their [ __ ] is
[ __ ] ridiculous like Egypt should be
[ __ ] bulldozed okay
like it's like they don't follow traffic
laws goats get out of [ __ ] buses in
the middle of anyway yeah careful all
the oil money is going to like one
family they're not they're not helping
their own people yeah like that [ __ ] is
the thing that Creole money's being
unfunded they fund right these
terrorists actually my point is is that
everyone's enclosed our fault just
listen everyone's in cahoots right and I
believe right that if we were attacked
our response wouldn't be not my point
I'm trying to make to you is this but
just what it convinced me no no if we
were attacked there would be no it would
galvanize everybody like it did after
9/11 I don't know what what we did was
we get some
nothing to do doesn't matter a [ __ ]
action doesn't matter but but that was
still the mandate was given go do
something what you're saying is what
they did wasn't proper okay I'm telling
you though all right so before that all
right so a country was like go it'll do
something so if Isis attacks us right we
will do something and we'll attack China
still missing the point I'm not missing
any point something bad happens the
whole country's gonna be like all right
we're okay with you doing whatever like
won't be any look at what happened in
like in [ __ ] the last drop a bomb on
Iran if they Belgium did they catch
everyone from Belgium yet I think they
did the brothers yeah yeah but what war
Paris like all these things when they
can't [ __ ] like that happens those
people always end up dead the first time
I've ever seen that somebody not end up
dead is that guy from the Boston
Marathon oh yeah usually the cop the
government I thought you know what I
call him they don't [ __ ] around with
sweetie pie I know he's evil and this is
what [ __ ] right because we're more
Rolling Stones put him on the cover of
the magazine women write him and you
know he has women followers and how do
you make with the rock star how dare you
make him look like a rock star what does
this say this he's a [ __ ] evil little
[ __ ] and he deserved to die that's a
Georgia do these cute you're talking
about the younger one tsarnaev is not
supporting him saying that people gonna
misconstrue that if he wasn't a
terrorist that suck his dick Bobby
thinks the guy's cute you know he said
he's okay with terrorism that's how
people do yeah usually those people end
up dead you know when you hear about a
shooter or something right the next day
it's like what in a guy the shooter dies
in every time yeah Columbine am I gonna
get trouble for saying that just now
that's are not as cute no he has a feel
that was suck a stick of he wasn't a
terrorist
[Laughter]
[Music]